if you watched our previous video you're
already familiar with how bigquery
stores your data
but how does bigquery actually process
your data and execute queries
understanding what goes on behind the
scenes is key to ensuring your queries
will run super fast
in this video we'll walk through the
life of a query and show you how to
leverage the query plan to troubleshoot
and optimize your sql
let's begin with an overview of
bigquery's architecture
in our last video we talked about
google's distributed file system that
stores bigquery data
colossus but to actually compute data
bigquery uses dremel
the query engine here workers or slots
like we discussed in our video on jobs
and the reservation model
are used to extract data from storage
and perform aggregations
to increase the performance each of
these slots does work independently from
one another
instead of communicating directly with
each other they use what we call
the remote memory shuffle to store
intermediary results
in bigquery each shuffled row can be
consumed by slots as soon as it's
created
which makes it possible to execute
distributed operations in a pipeline
all this data movement is facilitated by
jupiter
our super fast google scale network
now that you understand the architecture
let's see what happens inside of
bigquery when you actually submit a
query to be run
first off an api request will be sent
with all the details of the query
to proceed there's some level of api
processing that must occur
for example authenticating and
authorizing the request
and building and tracking metadata such
as the sql statement
cloud project and query parameters
next bigquery will perform lexing and
parsing
lexing refers to the process of scanning
an array of bytes
in this case the raw sequel statement
and converting that
into a series of tokens parsing
is the process of consuming those tokens
to build up a syntactical tree
representation of the query
which can be validated and understood by
bigquery software
while lexing and parsing are underway
bigquery will also perform
catalog resolution this basically means
that bigquery will resolve references to
entities like tables
views procedures and functions
as a more fully formed picture of the
request emerges bigquery begins to build
a query plan
here bigquery will use different
techniques to refactor and improve the
query
including adapting it to run as a set of
distributed execution tasks
once bigquery has the plan in place it
will work through the query stages in
the execution graph
besides the slots that perform the work
of the query plan
itself additional thoughts monitor and
direct the overall progress
not only will these slots determine how
the work is queued and executed
but they can also leverage bigquery's
dynamic planning capabilities
to make on-the-fly adjustments to the
query plan that will further optimize
performance
finally when the query has finished
executing the results will be sent back
to you
the user awesome so now that you have a
picture of what happens behind the
scenes
when a query is submitted let's go a
little bit deeper
and see what one of those query plans
actually looks like
here i'm going to run a simple query to
count the number of trips that began at
a station with broadway in the name
against the city bike data available in
bigquery's public data sets
in this first stage of the query plan a
set of slots will
access the distributed storage to read
in the table
the input table is actually made up of a
set of input file blocks
for each input block a slot is needed to
process the file
read and filter down the rows
each worker then writes one record into
shuffle that contains the partial count
for that input file
this second stage here reads from those
shuffle records as its input
and then sums them together it then
writes the output file
into a single file which becomes
accessible
as the results of the query in the
console
after you run a query you can view the
query plan to see this in action
in the execution details we can see the
average and maximum times each worker
spent in the wait phase
where the engine is waiting for either
slots to become available
or for a previous stage to start writing
results that it can begin consuming
in the read phase where the worker is
reading data either from colossus or
from shuffle
in the compute phase where the actual
processing takes place
such as evaluating sql functions or
expressions
and in the right phase where the shuffle
output is written in the next stage or
in the final output table
using the query execution details we can
clearly see the different stages of the
query plan
like we showed before where the first
stage includes workers that read filter
and aggregate the data
and then write the results to the
shuffle
and in the second stage we read from the
shuffle aggregate the partial results
and then write out the final results
in addition to being available in the
console the query plan information can
be retrieved through the api
from the job response or by querying the
information schema
so what can you actually do with this
information
first off the query plan and timeline
statistics can help you
understand whether certain stages
dominate resource utilization
for example a join stage that generates
far more output rows than input rows
can indicate an opportunity to filter
early in that query
additionally if you notice a significant
difference between
average and maximum time spent by
workers
that could indicate data skew which
results in one worker having much more
data to process than the others
that can again represent an opportunity
to filter early
or if there is a lot of time spent on
cpu tasks
you may want to consider approximate
functions
which are often within one percent of
the exact function
armed with your new understanding of how
bigquery executes queries
you're now ready to dig in and start
troubleshooting your own sql statements
for more details on specific strategies
on how to optimize your sql queries
stay tuned for our next video thanks for
tuning in to this episode of bigquery
spotlight
and remember stay curious
[Music]
you